I sort of went back and forth about
whether to even do this story because
there is so much resistance now to any
Russia related news either you already
understand what happened or you've
totally bought into the witch-hunt
conspiracy theory type stuff so I really
was unsure about whether to even talk
about this but in the end this is
actually really big news and I decided
it was an important story to do the
Senate Intelligence Committee which is
controlled by Republicans in a new
report has found that the Kremlin
directed Russia's social media meddling
in the 2016 election period and this is
it's becoming or it should be a post
partisan issue
the republican-led Senate Intelligence
Committee has a long list of
recommendations for Congress and for
Donald Trump and for social media
companies to prevent the same thing from
happening in 2020 but we've already seen
Senate Majority Leader Moscow Mitch
McConnell block every single effort to
prevent 20:20 meddling so it's going to
be an uphill battle the report suggests
that social media companies add
transparency to the sources of political
advertisements on their platforms that
they notify users about exposure to
misinformation and hilariously
hilariously in a depressing sense the
panel report recommends that the Trump
administration remind voters about the
dangers of foreign interference in 2020
I laughed out loud when I read that how
quaint right the Trump administration
should really warn people that warned
people that they benefit from it they
have no interest in stopping it why on
earth would they warn people this is the
whole problem that we're dealing with
many of the techniques and the players
that are mentioned in the report were
already known to us they talked about
the IRA the internet research agency
they were a big player they talked about
one strategy that we knew about which
was to target black Americans
particularly in parts of the country
like Baltimore in Ferguson Missouri
which were experiencing racial unrest
and specifically target those areas
black voters in those areas to foment
more racial unrest
the real news here is not any of that we
knew all of that stuff the news is that
we've learned that the Kremlin itself
was directing it and that conclusion was
reached not by you know whoever Trump
claims it was reached by it was reached
by a bipartisan panel that is led and
controlled by Republicans not a partisan
Democratic hack job or whatever Donald
Trump will obviously claim now let's do
the normal disclaimers here because I
think that this is where maybe some on
the left start to I don't know about
pushback but they start to question this
entire story which is extraordinarily
well backed by evidence Russia does not
only meddle in our elections right so
when we talk about Russian meddling in
our elections I'm not asserting nor
implying nor have I heard anyone assert
or imply that Russia only metals in
American elections they meddle in others
too and in fact that's what makes us so
sure that it's happening that it is not
atypical for Russia to be meddling in
others elections
the difference is other countries seem
more committed in stopping them other
countries seem more interested in
preventing it from happening now let's
go to the next disclaimer or it's not
even really a disclaimer it's just
context the United States also has a
long history of meddling in other
elections and you will sometimes hear
people on the left sometimes the
Leninist left say who are we to say
anything
we've been meddling in elections for a
really long time yeah okay so countries
try to meddle in the elections of other
countries for their own benefit that
doesn't change anything about wanting to
stop Russia from doing it right and
wanting to stop Russia from doing it
specifically for the benefit of Donald
Trump I was reminded when reading about
this of the words of a great modern
philosopher Donald J Trump who once said
he said it quite recently in fact you
know what we used to do in the old days
when we were smart with treason we used
to handle it a little bit differently
than we do now very interesting words on
such an occasion
if you were Vladimir Putin on the day
after the November of 2016 election how
do you prevent death from uncontrollable
laughter when you see that it worked
when you see that you succeeded mmm I
listen I don't know every instance of
Russian meddling in foreign elections
over the last hundred years I so I can't
say with certitude but has there been
any greater accomplishment by Russian
meddling in foreign elections than the
election of Donald Trump I'm asking the
question if somebody has an example that
is more egregious or notable or whatever
I want to hear it from you and I hope
that at a certain point because I know
that listen just every story I do is a
balance there's a risk and a reward to
every story that I choose or just
stories that I choose to exclude from
the show I know enough to know that
there is a nonzero part of my audience
my core audience even that believes the
witch-hunt never nothing nothing there
we're actually the bad guys meddling
elsewhere and Russia didn't do anything
to us conspiracy theory because that's
actually the real conspiracy theory I
know that there are people in my
audience who have fallen for that try to
separate your reflexive reaction that
has been built up over the last two and
a half years often on very bad reporting
and just understand that this is a
bipartisan Republican led report that
has found this if you want to argue that
they had bad data and thus their
conclusions are wrong make that argument
but make it with data don't just call it
a witch-hunt don't fall for the
Republican talking points because one of
the ways you don't even people may not
even understand this and this is a real
problem one of the ways that the right
wins is when they convince the left to
adopt their talking points when we start
making the same stupid arguments that
they make using the same language
particularly when they're wrong of
course we lose hard because we
completely lose any ability to see
common sense and reason and rationality
so that's my request don't fall for that
this weekend we are having
membership blowout we are it's been like
a year or longer since we've done this
membership is available year-round and
it's our number one funding source this
weekend we are going to have a one-day
membership blow out our biggest fun
membership drive of the year the only
one we've done this year actually which
by definition makes it the biggest we
are going to do a single day massive
discount off of memberships you can sign
up at a major discount if you so choose
all you have to do is get on our
newsletter our newsletter subscribers
will get an email this weekend the
subject will be something like that
email you've been waiting for or that
discount code I've been telling you
about and it will give you the
instructions to take advantage of this
Bigley I mean this is just huge huge
membership discount so get on our
newsletter at david pakman.com while
you're doing stuff follow me on twitter
at d Pakman follow the show on twitter
at david pakman show and a lot of people
asking me on twitter over the last day
or two will i be streaming next week's
democratic debate and i don't know if
people are asking me that because of my
recent
appendectomy and I've not been streaming
or because of the copyright issues we've
had with debates on CNN before my goal
is to be streaming the debate next week
and I will have more information about
where that will be happening early next
week
quick break big Friday show for you
today
do it cappucci paid for de Grazia Mila
one of our sponsors making the David
Pakman show possible is Babel the
language learning app and you'll get 25%
off a subscription to babble when you
click the link under this video
Babel was founded in 2007 and now has
over a million paying subscribers
worldwide as one of the world's leading
language learning apps they're learning
method has been examined numerous times
in scientific studies including one at
Yale in 2019 which found that 100
percent of participants who used babble
were able to improve their oral
proficiency with a new language within
just three months research found that
users learning Spanish on babble only
needed to use the app for an average of
15 hours over a two-month period to
cover the
quirements for one college semester of
Spanish I recently went to Italy and
used Babel to brush up on my Italian for
a few weeks leading up to the trip and I
was actually surprised at how much I was
able to absorb in such a short amount of
time
after practicing Italian on the babble
app I was able to hold some
conversations with locals in Italy I
could understand a lot more of the
Italian that I was hearing and the
progress I made was extremely inspiring
in keeping me going and continuing to
use the app to get even better I'm also
about to use the app to start learning
German which I'm looking forward to I
really would recommend Babel to anyone
who watches our show and you can save
25% on a subscription to Babel when you
click the link right underneath this
video